awesome
on Ukraine's front line they fire at
Russian Targets in a brutal
counter-offensive
[Applause]
the Ukrainian Armed Forces say these
images show two battalions locked in
battles
the infighting in Moscow has no
immediate impact on the real fighting
here
but as senior politician said Ukrainian
forces sense weakness in Russia's
divided lines
I think that now in Grain has a very
good window of opportunity to do
something how we will exploit how
successfully we will see next several
weeks
Russian mercenaries at the heart of this
weekend's aborted Uprising were a crude
but lethal force in Vladimir Putin's
Arsenal
they captured the eastern city of bakmut
in the bloodiest battle of the war so
far
it means the rift between the head of
the Wagner group and Russia's military
Chiefs can only be good news for Ukraine
yevgeny pregosin even openly defied
Putin by accusing Moscow of lying to the
public over its justification for the
entire Invasion we were always saying
that Russia as an empire built on lies
will sooner or later implode so
something tells me that what happened
yesterday is probably just the beginning
of a larger
self-destruction of this Empire of evil
and of course what makes Russia weaker
makes us stronger and brings our Victory
closer
Ukraine keep fighting
in fact analysts say the instability in
Russia should Harden Western resolve to
keep up the supply of weapons to keep
fortunately Ukrainian Victory Is
Possible only in situation when Ukraine
will do it will do this job
but that will facilitate destruction
which started in Russia and it will I
think it will go faster and faster
for Ukraine soldiers they just want to
win back their territory if Victory also
prompts The Accelerated demise of
Putin's regime that would be an added
bonus debraham Sky News